uh marjorie taylor green has appeared on
conspiracy theorist alex jones infowars
and she wants to make it known that she
is not crazy she says it bothers her to
be treated like she's a crazy person
this is all starting to be beyond parody
let's take a listen to marjorie taylor
green and it just bothers me so much
they treat me um as if i'm some kind of
crazy person
like i have three horns coming out of my
head but what they don't understand is
they're the ones that are crazy right
everybody else is crazy she's not
everything she does is completely normal
and by the way she says this with an
infowars sign behind her which is a
choice to do that and she seems unable
to realize that alex jones is crazy um
it's very similar to
mike lindell
claiming
to have evidence that is going to put
300 million people behind bars
and then saying everybody else is crazy
because they don't realize the evidence
is so obvious at a certain point a
non-crazy person and i get that these
i'm not i'm not literally using these
terms i'm not stigmatizing mental
illness but wacky maybe we use wacky or
disconnected from reality at a certain
point
a person who's connected to reality
would realize when you say you have
evidence to imprison 300 million people
for their role in the 2020 election you
would realize
i'm the wacky one right and it's the
exact same thing with marjorie taylor
green just completely disconnected from
her own reality that she's saying
outrageous things that no serious sane
person could possibly believe she also
is uh continuing to say them even as she
claims to be not crazy
at an event in texas over the weekend
which we talked about earlier earlier in
the week she says you know aoc was a
bartender so she's not smart
okay
where is that energy going to be created
y'all
solar and wind
don't you know
come on aoc is so much smarter than all
of us she was a bartender
right
[Applause]
right
you silly conservative republicans
you probably have small businesses and
things like that
shame on you independent people that
know how to balance a checkbook
in all seriousness
people can be smart coming from all
walks of life i know people who have
every type of job you could imagine and
they are smart people okay
but is marjorie taylor green's
background really anything to number one
prove her intelligence and number two to
put her in a position to make fun of
other people's work backgrounds like
marjorie taylor green's dad gave her and
her husband his general contracting
company oh okay wow well so she ran a
business well the atlanta journal
constitution investigated and they
determined she has had no significant
presence at the company whatsoever so
she sort of didn't really run the
company her dad gave her she then
started crossfit training
and ended up founding a crossfit gym
and if we all wanted to play the game
that she's playing we could say well
i'm sure marjorie taylor green is smart
i mean she had a crossfit gym right it's
sort of like neither here nor there
but we can only be led to believe that
marjorie taylor green thinks bartenders
aren't intelligent but crossfit people
are bartenders aren't qualified to be
members of congress but crossfit gym
owners
are and in reality what we need are
measures like can you think critically
do your beliefs follow from the evidence
do you have a normal level of empathy
with which you can understand situations
that other people are in and then the
last thing i'll say about this also is
you know they they claim that they are
about
the working people
they are against the so-called elites
now half the time when they mean elites
they just mean jews and it's an
anti-semitic cover like when they say
globalist you know you guys understand
that these are often coded words now but
if you're for the middle class if you're
for the working man and woman
um then why
would it be disqualifying
that aoc was a bartender and so of
course their principle that they are for
the little guy
uh falls apart very quickly through
their own elitism that is very clearly
displayed in this way even though
marjorie taylor green has really nothing
in her background that would make her
uh feel like an elite by her own
standards and it's pathetic and it's
disgusting and we should remember their
stated principles are abandoned as soon
as they want to make a point against one
of their political enemies